what inspired you to want to write a
book on the united states of war a
global history of america's endless
conflicts from columbus to islamic state
in short i think we have to stop
fighting
i think the united states has been
fighting far too much
for far far too long and we've gotta
choose another path
uh you know more than a quarter of the
country now has no memory of a time when
the united states was not at war
more than a quarter of the country
cannot remember a day in their lives
when the united states was not at war
we've been a war for 20 consecutive
years since the us invaded afghanistan
in 2001
and when i began research for this book
i thought this was
fairly exceptional in u.s history and i
came to find that actually this is the
norm in u.s history that the united
states military has been fighting in
almost every year of u.s history
since independence
all but 11 years the united states
military has been involved in some kind
of a war or other form of combat and
i put simply i we we need to stop
fighting uh this the fighting this
really endless forever war that we've
been fighting has not only
damaged and taken the lives of millions
of people around the world it's been in
ways that i think are often invisible to
us harming the vast majority of people
in the united states in profound ways
did you say we've we've been at war with
somebody from inception 1776 till today
except for 11 years
that's great that's right and that's
based on a list that the congressional
research service puts together
um and which i've updated uh with the
help of others
uh yeah um
sorry what were those 11 years
uh there were a few years at the end of
the 19th century a few years during the
the roosevelt administration when he
uh in addition to the the new deal uh
brought into effect what he called the
good neighbor policy where he ended a
long pattern of invading latin american
countries in particular a few years and
then
late 1970s but you know by some accounts
the united states has never been at
peace uh there are other you know cia
interventions um coups um other forms of
of warfare that the united states has
been engaged in arguably in every year
since independence so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you